BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 172nd episode!
BAU BAU!
Good Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Are you sure you're Fuwawa?
I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not a chihuahua!
I am not a chihuahua!
You seem confused on joining this...cast here.
I don't know, you know, my voice is kinda like... Maybe you might think, that's a chihuahua.
I'm not a chihuahua!
I am Fuwawa!
Okay?
Got it?
It can be surprising sometimes.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show.
Held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be blah blah blah, but chill!
Temporarily on Mondays, once a week.
So we can get some more balance.
Yes!
And that's been going well.
Yes.
I aim to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
I really, really felt it this time, Moco-chan.
I felt it inside your soul.
I did.
I feel like, you know, this is gonna be a good week.
Yes!
Start it off on the right paw.
What?
Let's all do it, okay, FUWAMOCO?
FUWAMOCO-chan, you know it's a big weekend.
Huh?
Why?
But there was really good things going on, like a celebration.
Huh?
No.
Nice pen.
What?
Moco-chan!
A sneeze?
That's not bad.
Moco-chan, don't sneeze on me!
BAU!
You see it, Moco-chan?
Another Pero Sighting!
BAU BAU!
Hi.
Well.
You didn't just happen to sneeze a Pero out of your... No?
No?
The wolf means I'm the wolf.
Okay.
Pero Sighting.
Oh, where was Pero Sighted this time?
Let's take a look.
De-den!
Ruffians!
What the heck?!
You need to do something about this!
Hai!
Ruffians, are you just going to let Pero be all cuddly and snug under the blankets with the FUWAMOCO on either side?
Hi.
No.
You can't do this!
You have to get him out of there!
It's nasty!
You know, get him some pudding.
Pudding, yeah.
I don't know Ruffians.
He looks really comfy.
Not lucky, no!
Awful!
Yeah, I think you know pudding's the only thing that's gonna get him out of there.
I do that with punches.
But if you give him pudding, then he'll have pudding, right?
Yeah, but of all things, I think you know there's one way to solve this?
Misha, so lock your doors and your windows too, okay?
Yeah.
Safety.
Okay?
Otherwise...
This might happen to you.
Bye Pero.
Feeling a bit eepy?
You can't be swayed!
Yeah... No, it doesn't matter!
It doesn't matter if he's eepy!
Pero, doggy, but it's cushion size!
It's not!
Ruffians!
We really want to hug you.
We want to protect you.
We want you to protect your smile, Ruffians, but... Not like this.
This is not how it works.
Be careful!
Got it!
Lock your doors.
Lock your windows, okay?
And make sure to have pudding in the fridge.
At all times.
Emergency.
For you and for him.
BAU BAU!
Got it.
Over!
Pero be squished.
Squished?
Squish him!
Squash him!
Smash him!
Destroy him!
That's a lot of violent words there, Moco-chan.
Why not?
You know, I guess we could blend them too.
Blend?
Does it blend?
Pero edition!
BAU BAU!
We're starting the day on the right paw.
Does it blend?
Sometimes you know it's good to have a smoothie in the morning.
Morning smoothie!
Pero edition.
Recently there was something very exciting that happened!
Yes, read our minds, do it!
First thing in the morning, I know you can mind read!
Nope, nope, too late.
It was hololive English's 5th Anniversary Advent on Midsummer's Anniversary!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
A big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big, big,
You know, it's a really big celebration!
Without all the men who worked so so hard and continues to work really hard, we wouldn't be here right now.
So a very big big thank you!
All the respect and congratulations!
But to celebrate, they all did a bunch of amazing things!
Lots of fun!
Hey, how'd you know?
Kiara-chan-pon!
She did a bunch of different celebrations, fun things!
But she also did some 3D karaoke as well!
Cute new outfit!
Right!
It's a new one, I think, right?
She looks amazing in red!
Red really suits her!
Right!
The whole theme too!
Yeah, we're sort of matching with the chains here!
Okay, Moco.
Matching.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
But it was a really really fun time for all the KFBs!
It is a tasty outfit!
I thought I recognized it!
But it's not my real color, no!
No, it's in multiple colors in the PV.
That's right.
I don't know, maybe it's... Was there chains on it?
Maybe I just forgot.
Moco-chan, it's your fifth anniversary.
Not Kiara-san, but she's going on to her sixth year.
Everything just looks kind of more exquisite now, right?
That's what happens when you level up.
She's blue and red?
Is it the accessories?
I don't know.
It looks very, very fashionable.
Stunning.
And Calli-senpai!
She celebrated her 5th anniversary with a very special 3D VR chat stream!
What's this, Moco-chan?
We swam and danced together, although it may not look like it there.
And not just us two, all of hololive are there singing and dancing together with Calli-senpai!
And you know, she also did some reminiscing of some very special places over
For the past five years in VRChat 2.
And well, it wasn't our first time, you know, singing just alone with Calli-senpai, but it was our first time singing one of her songs!
And the fans are really excited!
Camouflage!
Calli-senpai picked camouflage, but we are very happy because we have lots of memories of it too.
Although, I must say I never imagined us singing that together with Calli-senpai.
So, I'm really happy that amazing things continue to happen as well.
We're still getting used to VRChat.
We're getting used to VRChat.
And, of course, we had to do one thing.
Yeah!
We had to hug Calli-senpai!
It was a very funny feeling.
It was amazing seeing her so close up like this.
Right?
It was a new outfit too.
I was right up in her armpit.
Yeah!
Moco-chan, you have to say it like that!
I mean, you can see the proof is right there.
Yeah!
But it was a lot of fun.
We hope to be able to do more things like this together via chat as well.
But also can't accept but at the end of her celebration, she released a new song called Orpheus!
Yeah BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
It has very cute lyrics and very cute animation too!
Very funky!
Yeah, so please check it out.
I feel like, you know, Calli-senpai, she continues to release a new song that does something very different from all the previous songs, too.
I really love that, you know.
Yeah, keep on, you know, surprising us, even reading, you know.
Right, yeah.
So please go have a listen!
And well, Ina-senpai!
In true Ina-senpai fashion, she had a very chill, relaxing celebration.
She looked at a very, very sweet project made by all the Takodachi and then also shared that she has an Ina Academy project that she's gonna be doing with the Takodachi.
Sounds like a lot of fun!
Ina Academy yo!
I hope that a lot of takodachi have fun doing it because they'll make me so nervous!
I will be!
Mina-senpai, look at my artwork!
Let's not, let's not make her suffer.
Yeah, yeah.
No, it's okay.
I was doing my best to draw and watch the other day while we were doing some recording.
I didn't want to hand back the script.
No, because usually you know at the end the staff is going to take the scripts back.
Yeah, I was like, wait, we'll take this one home.
Yeah, I had a whole bunch of little drawings.
Can we call that on it?
Yeah.
I told her to leave it on.
I don't think Staff-san looked at it.
Yeah, fair.
I see.
But we had a bunch of fun things going on.
And then also all Mifco together had a collab.
When they announced that they will be having a 5th anniversary 3D collab soon!
It's going to be happening on the hololive English official channel.
On, is this correct?
The 20th at 8pm PT.
Is this correct?
Confirm.
Is that the correct time?
Help.
I believe that is the time.
Completely off the top of my head.
Help.
On the 21st.
Yes, yes, yes.
In Japan.
That's right.
We're trying to celebrate.
Fortune Spinner!
We know what time it is in Japan, but... Help.
Help.
Is that time?
It is quick.
Thank you!
Okay, thank you!
That's what it is.
At 8pm PT, so please make sure to tune in there.
Is that a 7?
Huh?
Is it 7?
It could be 7.
It could be 8.
Be preparable.
Yes.
Get ready for 6pm PT and then you're ready if it's at 8pm PT or 7pm.
Somewhere within the window of 6 to 7 to 8.
Yes.
It's 8.
I don't know.
FUWAMOCO!
Figure it out!
I'm looking forward to it!
This anniversary is a huge one!
Yes!
But um, you know Moco-chan, we're on our third year in July.
Next year, that would be our third anniversary.
Not that far away.
It's not that far away.
Are you panicked?
You should be panicked.
I'm not panicked, but I'm just like... I'm saying the Ruffians should be panicked!
Why?
Panic now.
Panic.
Time goes so fast.
So, so, so, so, so fast.
Yeah.
Ball time!
What the heck?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Congratulations on 5 years!
5 years since hololive English was born.
Amazing.
BAU BAU!
And also over this very important weekend, there was um...
Tournament shenanigans.
Yes, uh... Advent and Justice going into a bit of a fight.
Ow!
Fighting!
Using, you know, traditional methods.
Ow!
Like... Chess!
Chess!
Yes!
Advent versus Justice!
In chess!
Yes, we have a very important tournament.
Consisting of a one hour practice.
But...
Not just one hour practice, one hour lesson.
Very jam-packed one hour lesson with Olympic level coaches.
Right?
So now I'm like an Olympian.
They had to teach us what the names of the pieces were.
The horse goes gallop, gallop, gallop.
Side to side.
Yeah.
I'll never forget that.
But, is it a horse or a knight?
I don't know.
Horse!
Horse, yeah.
But we had a lot of fun.
We had our training.
And then, well, just yesterday we had the big tournament.
Yes, and best out of one.
Advent Deathmatch and Chess.
Advent.
One.
But that's okay because, you know, we always beat justice.
And as you know, the senpai start to feel a little bit bad.
Yeah.
So we had to give them this one.
We didn't want them to suffer anymore.
Yeah, you know.
We didn't start to run away with our king.
No.
Just like, you can always outrun a child, but if you're playing tag, you can't just... You have to let them tag you.
Tag you in.
Right?
Imagine you're playing tag with a child.
You can just run away from them.
Faster, right?
Oh, so this is the same?
Yeah.
Justice is a child.
I can run faster than Justice.
No matter what they say!
But they'll be sad if I don't let them go tag, right?
If you understand, that's what's important.
Okay, Ruffians?
Thank you, Ruffians.
You understand.
You got lost?
What the heck?
BAU BAU!
And at the end of that...
Moco-chan, you're just gonna go on like that?
There's more things that happen!
Go ahead.
I got lost in the tank, you know.
You got lost too, just like the Ruffians.
Very lost.
Well, we learned some very special techniques.
Like castling, right Moco-chan?
Right, eventually.
And we learned that.
And we had a very specific plan all of Advent.
This will happen, Moco-chan.
You are going to be the part that I'm not good at.
Doing the castling part.
I'm done!
Do it a bit.
Something happened and it was not my fault.
It wasn't your fault.
Whose fault was it?
Nerissa's.
It wasn't Nerissa's fault, Moco-chan!
I didn't blame it on Nerissa.
It wasn't a technical issue, right?
Then it was Shiori's.
It was a technical issue.
It was, it was... Yeah.
Moco-chan, she said that maybe Fuwawa's fault.
It was a technical one.
Moco-chan, you were wrong, right?
I was not wrong, I did exactly right.
All of it was just a shock.
Hi.
But it was a lot of fun!
And for the lessons, we also had Aoi-senpai as MC and for the actual tournament we had Calli-senpai as MC as well!
Amazing job by the two of them!
Calli-senpai said she was like a DJ.
Right, and she was just supposed to be an MC but she was a DJ MC.
Yeah.
One thing that's a little bit embarrassing though is that Advent, I think a lot of us thought that you could not hear us.
So we're just being really silly.
But focused, but silly.
Like we usually are all just together.
So... Yeah.
You can sometimes hear, we're just like, oh, you can't hear us.
When you two did it was extra silly.
That's how it goes.
That's how we do it.
But even though we lost on purpose, we had a lot of fun!
And it was really nice to MC recently FUWAMOCO!
We had something really nice happen!
We heard that a certain zombie happens to be a little bit of an early riser.
So we went for breakfast together with Aoi-senpai!
It was really nice!
Sharing pancakes together and just chatting about silly things.
You know what's funny?
I...
I had a hot chocolate.
I never ever drink hot chocolate.
Aoi-senpai and I, we both got matcha.
I felt like I was going to throw up.
It was good though!
Was it good?
Very decadent.
First thing in the morning?
Nomadeca.
Yeah.
But it was nice.
And that was chess.
Um, that was chess.
But the announcement!
Yes!
At the end of the 10 events, there was an exciting announcement!
Wow!
There's not one!
Mushi-kun!
Advent Vs. Justice and the very first chapter was just released on the hololive English official channel.
You can go and please check it out there.
It is 12 minutes and very cinematic, very amazing, beautiful art by Yomosaka-sensei.
Yes!
Amazing!
Thank you!
Yeah, if you want to learn more about, you know, Advent and Justice back when we were in the cell, this is for you.
And if you go comment on our pinned comment,
No, you probably want to see an anime.
We want to see an anime.
Maybe.
Don't you think it'll be cool?
I'm just saying, you know, anime.
Anime.
Right.
You know, Advent versus Justice, the animation.
Titles, it's done.
Confirmed.
No, no confirmed.
Can we get a better title?
Thank you.
Please go take a look!
There's gonna be a new chapter every month being released on the hololive English official channel!
So please stay tuned for more!
You know, you might think, oh 12 minutes, wow, that's quite sizable.
Goes by in a flash, so please take a look!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And maybe not so hololive news, but still hololive news!
FUWAMOCO news!
Well, we had something silly happen.
On a movie trip together!
Movie trip!
A trip to the movie theater!
It wasn't meant for... not for us.
It's a trip.
The first time in FOREVER we went to see a movie in the theaters!
And that's because the last movie we saw in theaters was Kimi no Na wa.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
No seatbelts?
No seatbelts.
I would have appreciated that.
Yeah, but there was a big warning being like you could probably spill your drinks and your food, so... Yeah, be prepared.
That's the risk you take here.
But it was a very good movie!
Yeah!
You know, if you have the chance, I think it's worth going to see.
But, you know, when you go to the movie theater, you can't pop in.
Yeah, and we were really surprised because, uh, I know back in the Makai, there's movie theaters, but
It's very, very, very expensive.
Very expensive.
And just so you know, we got a huge popcorn bucket like this big.
It was too big.
Massive popcorn bucket.
And two big drinks.
Yeah.
It was... Not even $10.
How to say popcorn in Japanese?
Popcorn!
It's easy!
Wow!
Popcorn!
It could have had different flavors like caramel or like butter and shoyu.
Whatever you want.
Other things.
Do it with salt.
Yeah.
But, you know, it was so nice having FUWAMOCO for the first time in a long time too.
Moco-chan, you were kind of hogging it all to yourself.
I was not!
You were!
I didn't get to eat any.
The movie was really quiet so we had to stop before the movie started.
But... I held onto the bucket, okay?
Okay, and... You did eat some.
Because... There was an incident.
There is an incident.
It's ongoing.
It's ongoing-san.
Oh, Moco-chan.
Well... I have, you know, the pop of the- the part of the popcorn.
But the popcorn?
The part of the popcorn.
The little- the shell of the kernel.
Yeah.
It's stuck in the back of my throat.
And I can't get it out.
I have tried so hard before the movie started.
I was like, ah, it's stuck back there, you know?
So I was like, okay, I'll drink water.
I'll drink water, I'll drink the drink.
Now.
No.
I tried.
I didn't choke, it's just stuck there.
And then I tried eating more.
Still stuck.
Go back.
Dig gargle.
No.
Still stuck.
Drink tea.
Eat food.
Still stuck.
Talk lots.
Sing a bit.
Still stuck.
You know, all this stuff.
I tried.
And?
I said cough really hard.
I coughed really hard.
I tried to get it out.
Toothbrush.
Moco-chan keeps on asking Fuwawa help me!
I'm not gonna help you!
Don't throw up!
Moco-chan!
It won't come out!
I don't know!
Natto?
Natto you sure?
Natto is sticky.
Did it try sneezing?
What did I just do?
It won't come out.
And I'm worried.
I have to call the doctor.
You don't need to go to the doctor.
I can't see it, but I know it's there.
Are you sure it's actually there now?
I'm sure.
You know, I can feel it.
Maybe it's just in your mind.
No, it's there!
It'll go away after a bit.
I think so too.
Moco-chan's just, you know, very pessimistic at times.
It's scratchy!
She's asking for my help lots!
She won't do anything!
Can you shine a light and see if you see something?
She goes, no!
Ruffians, what do you do if Moco-chan comes up to you and asks for help like that?
Just laugh at her.
You're good, Moco-chan.
You're good!
Shiori should take a look.
She'd probably be amused.
Help!
What can you do to help them realistically?
Give her a hug!
Have pants!
Thank you.
Moco-chan, you want a hug right now?
I don't need a hug.
I'm like... No!
No!
Just a really strong hug!
I tried!
I tried the gargle!
Not with salt water!
No!
That's just gross.
That sounds good though.
No.
So... Let's hope for the best!
Shrink down and fight!
What?
BAU BAU!
You're good!
We had fun.
Popcorn was yummy!
BAU BAU!
Well, there's also another announcement from hololive English.
About something very mysterious.
hololive Nexus Gate.
What is this?
Yes, the hololive English official pop-up store!
The Chronicles of hololive English The Nexus Gate.
Act 1.
The Portal Awakens.
It will be starting October 6th to November 2nd and happening at the American Dream Shopping Mall in New Jersey!
Pop-up store!
New Jersey!
New toys, awesome merchandise sales, and meet and greet events starring hololive English talents!
And it's all gonna be set around the theme of the next Escape Act 1, the Portal Awakens theme.
What is this?
Do you know what this is?
Well, there's a gate.
I don't know what nexus means, but there's a gate.
Do you know what it is?
I guess that also means like a portal?
Chronicles?
I don't know.
Do I know what this is?
It's an intense theme.
It's something.
Now, maybe I'll go through this gate and that's how we do the meet and greets?
That'd be cool.
It's like a dokodemo door.
Dokodemo door!
That'd be cool.
There'll be more details soon.
But FUWAMOCO, we really hope that we'll be part of the chosen ones.
To see you at the Nexus Gate in New Jersey.
What's happening in New Jersey?
Nexus Gate.
Nobody knows.
BAU BAU!
It's important!
You have to unveil the mystery.
BAU BAU!
You know, such big exciting things we just had off for one, now miss anniversary, and then a 3D concert!
And now, next is game.
New toys.
It's gonna be a good week, Ruffians!
Maybe there's some Ruffians that are still feeling a little bit unsure of FUWAMOCO-chan.
Hai.
Is it a key to the Makai?
No.
Okay, that's it.
Chippity-chop-chop done now.
Pup Talk!
Pup Talk.
You wanna Pup Talk that bad?
Yeah.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
BAU BAI!
So many really deeply touched Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Let's take a look at some very special corners on the Ruffians.
First we have the Doggie of the Day!
These doggies, they are... De-den!
Cute!
If I don't have a name... Today's Doggie of the Day is... FUNNY DEMON DOG!
BAU BAU!
She looks a little shy.
A little concerned.
Cute dog.
Maybe she's, you know, camera shyness.
That makes sense, you know.
She likes trees, huh?
Cute.
FUWAMOCO!
A third sister?
I don't know.
We'd be happy to have a third sister out of... No, she's this cute.
Her name is Peggy.
Peggy!
Cute.
Peggy aka furry demon dog.
It's a bit long, but...
What?
I was gonna say, you know, Peggy's a demon dog.
Huh?
I was thinking maybe we have to get a test to see if she's an actual demon dog.
But now that we know this is Peggy.
Peggy!
We don't need a test.
Yeah?
She just looks like a cute, cute... Peg.
BAU BAU!
How does Peggy BAU BAU?
What?
BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Has a guest waiting to be greeted?
You have the food!
She is happy.
She likes, you know?
All the good things.
Happy dog stuff.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
We have our other corner.
Today I went on a walk.
What do you mean other corner, Moco-chan?
Ruffians, let's see what you've been going on a walk, huh?
De-den!
A fishing trip!
Sunset fishing!
Fishing right in front of my dad.
Moco-chan's sunset?
I thought it looked like a sunset.
I don't think you usually go...
Fishing at sunset?
You can't!
But I don't think like this.
It looks like a sunset.
I think it's dawn, you know.
But the fish weren't biting.
Oh, maybe you should have went to sunset!
Why, Moco-chan?
What is there to get at sunset?
Maybe the fish would have been biting at sunset!
I think it's more dangerous at sunset.
But, Ruffians, isn't there like a saying about like the red dawn?
And that maybe it's not good to go fishing then, right?
Mococo Sky.
This is Red Dawn Sky.
Don't go fishing.
Bye.
Mococo Sky.
I'm trying to rhyme, I don't know.
Red Sky Morning.
Sailors take warning.
Ow.
Maybe that's why there's no fish.
Yeah.
Caught no fish, but it's okay because I see you caught lots of memories instead.
BAU BAU!
You don't call me lots of laughs.
You're like, there's no fish.
Yeah, maybe you know, caught dad's heart or something.
Caught dad's heart.
I'm sure that was already caught many many years before.
You already did it.
You didn't even have to go fishing.
BAU BAU!
Oh, sometimes it's actually a good time to fish.
I wanna go fishing!
I still wanna go fishing, Ruffians!
I wanna go fishing.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Nature's gotcha.
Our next corner is today's Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Lately you've been appearing in all sorts of recordings and sessions.
Have you been able to connect with other holomers in the studio and such?
I'm really looking forward to seeing lots of collaborations in the future!
BAU BAU!
Chatting with Ririka.
Matsuri-senpai.
Of course, you know, just have a day!
Bae-senpai, IRyS-senpai, Calli-senpai.
Bunch of people.
It's hot in here.
It's really hot.
But it's a... Senchou-senpai, too.
Mikocchi-senpai.
Korone-senpai.
Biboo ran in us before, too.
Ollie-senpai.
Kronii-senpai.
Lots of senpai.
I don't think so.
I really don't think so.
hololive.
JP.
THE BOYZ.
LADY.
And... Ah, Choco-senpai!
Yeah yeah yeah yeah!
Choco-senpai!
Yeah, of course!
Yeah!
We dance together with Choco-senpai.
Are you sure we met all of FUWAMOCO?
Yes, multiple times.
We met all of FUWAMOCO all at once.
Ayame-senpai, we will dance the solo dance!
Yeah!
Have you met FUWAMOCO?
I don't think I'm familiar with Mococo, but I do know Fuwawa.
Sometimes people say, are you Mococo?
No, I'm Fuwawa.
BAU BAU!
We're looking forward to even more special moments in the future.
You never know what's going to happen, huh?
Kanade, yes, of course!
Well, beings don't believe us, huh?
Nodoka yes!
I know, we have a howl of a day!
Towa-senpai yes!
Luna-senpai yes!
We talked about a bunch of different things with Luna-senpai.
Of course, you know, there's fast and everything too!
Kanata-senpai yes!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Wow, thank you so much for all your submissions!
Remember, please do not forget, FUWAMOCO Morning is something we make together with you, Ruffians.
So, we need you to share with us with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Please let us know what kind of walk has you been going on.
Maybe there is something new on your walking path.
What is this?
Is that about us?
Or maybe it's just a piece of paper.
Share it!
Okay!
If you have any Pero sightings, I know maybe you might not want to bring the mood down.
But we need to know.
We need to stay informed.
Important information.
Doggies of the day!
Please send us your cutest doggies!
Your silliest doggies!
They might be the Doggie of the Day!
And questions!
Ruffians!
I think it's been a little while since our last Q&A.
If you have lots of questions, please let us know with the hashtag, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Do we have another stream coming up?
Yes, we do!
It's a surprise still.
There's gonna be more streams later this week.
We'll be sharing them with you as soon as we can.
So if you're wondering what's gonna happen this week, please check our YouTube page, our Twitter page.
Subscribe to let you know as fast as possible.
Although if you want to know as soon as possible, check YouTube.
BAU BAU POPCORN!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Saiseki!
BAU BAU!
Konekojita!
Rumo-chan!
BAU BAU!
Balkin!
Twosome Cure.
BAU BAU!
Deacon Hunter.
Resnyo.
BAU BAU!
Mystic Woman.
Green Tear.
BAU BAU!
This is today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!